[Música]
bueno pues sin género garcía y siempre
me es muy difícil presentarme porque me
dedico a tantas actividades que me he
complicado
enumerar las son tantas incertidumbres a
lo largo de mi vida que tengo que buscar
una puerta para poder desentrañar las y
esa puerta es la de la formación
circunstancias yo no pude cursar nunca
estudios superiores pero eso no fue
excusa
para no crecer en conocimiento en la
formación está la información y en la
información
está la solución y en esos años
convulsos
yo la solución la encontré en la
educación en la educación en sus dos
roles
en el rol formativo y en el rol
conductual el rol formativo cuanto más
conocimiento tenga más despejado tendrá
el camino cuanta más sabiduría tendré
más posibilidades de encontrar esa
oportunidad que más tarde o más temprano
llegará a mi puerta
y el otro rol el conductual yo todos los
años
me hago la prueba de la alergia
y sabéis
lo que me sale
soy alérgico a los maleducados
qué importante saber decir hola adiós
gracias por favor y sobre todo y por
encima de todas las cosas saber pedir
perdón yo creo que con una buena
educación
y una sonrisa se abren todas las puertas
he sido limpia cristales he sido furgón
entero he sido camionero he sido
taxistas camareros yo portero de
discoteca sí o vigilante es el boxeador
escrito dos libros
y soy entrenador de boxeo
cuántas actividades pero si he sido
popular alguna vez ha sido por un
programa de televisión un programa
social que a través de la mediación
familiar
intentábamos
llevar la paz
a los hogares
tratábamos la violencia ascendente la
violencia filio-parental cuando los
chicos acosan a sus padres que es el
acoso
es cuando una persona hostiga molesta
vilipendia a otra de una forma violenta
esa violencia puede ser física psíquica
o verbal ese programa era un reality o
sea que todo lo que ocurría era real
pero paradojas del destino casi todo el
mundo pensaba que era mentira porque por
dos razones principales primero nadie
podía pensar que son niños
trataran así a sus padres con unas
cámaras delante
que eran actores
si esos niños fueran actores no estarían
en este país estarían en hollywood o en
broadway cuál es la otra razón por la
que la gente pensaba que podía ser
mentira por la cantidad de éxitos que
teníamos
llegábamos a las casas como cuales son
cistas y le sacábamos el mal a los niños
llegábamos como superhéroes con capa y
solucionábamos todo pero sabéis donde
seguro no están los héroes lo sabéis en
la televisión
allí los héroes brillan por su ausencia
los héroes están en otro sitio en otro
lugar saber dónde están los verdaderos
héroes
institutos universidades son esos
maestros que están intentando formar a
las chicas y los chicos para que sean
hombres y mujeres del mañana los
trabajadores y educadores sociales que
están peleando día a día contra la
exclusión social intentando prevenir las
violencias
los médicos los sanitarios los bomberos
los policías que se han jugado la vida
en esta pandemia por quién
por nosotros
esos son los verdaderos héroes
[Música]
no son héroes por las victorias no al
contrario son héroes
sus derrotas porque aún así teniendo
esas derrotas nunca jamás se dan por
vencidos porque ellos son ejemplares
ellos abrazan la ejemplaridad porque el
ejemplo puede ser bueno o puede ser malo
pero la ejemplaridad siempre tiene una
connotación positiva ser ejemplar cambia
el mundo
ser ejemplar conlleva un conflicto que
hace cambiar el mundo cuando tú te das
cuenta de que alguien es ejemplar que
alguien es digno
tienes dos opciones o lo admira solo
envidias si lo admiras vas a hacer todo
lo posible por ti mismo para ser mejor y
acercarte a esa persona sacar la mejor
versión de ti mismo pero sin embargo sí
le envidias
si le envidias vas a intentar ser igual
o tener lo que tiene la persona
envidiada
deseándole mal
ejemplaridad conflicto cambiar el mundo
pero es que el mundo muchas veces se
cambia a través de los conflictos porque
siempre que hay conflictos hay golpes
sabéis cuál fue el primer cabo de mi
carrera
no fue en un ring
fue en un pasillo el principio de los
años 90 en ese carabanchel profundo una
llamada de teléfono sí
soy yo la que oliera a mi novia de ese
tiempo los dime cariño
de hecho la prueba del predictor
imaginado que sabe lo que es el previsto
no la prueba el test de embarazo si sale
rosa bien acompañante si sale azul viene
vacío
qué color ha salido
muy rosa
imaginaros el golpe que me lleve que me
sentó de culo rematado unos meses
después cuando me pusieron en mis brazos
una niña de 3 kilos 250 gramos con los
ojos verdes más bonitos que había visto
en mi vida
y esos ojos
me dieron la luz me dieron me dieron la
luz que yo necesitaba para ver el camino
de la responsabilidad porque yo hasta
ese momento era
un salvaje de pelo largo con los brazos
tatuados que iban de espino
y abrace la responsabilidad con tanta
fuerza
que por primera vez en 20 años de mi
vida estuve motivado
porque es la motivación en la motivación
es hacer las cosas cuando estás bien
no
la verdadera motivación es hacer las
cosas cuando estás mal cuando estás
obligado a hacerlas porque por la
responsabilidad esa sí que es la
verdadera motivación si mi hija no
hubiera venido para insuflar me el
primer cado de mi carrera y para
salvarme la vida yo jamás hubiera sido
deportista de élite yo jamás hubiera
sido boxeador profesional
13 años 13 años siendo peleador
70 pelea subiendo me a un ring jugándome
la vida 15 fracturas de nariz
rotura las dos manos
roturas de fibras falta de pigmentación
en los ojos buscando qué
un sueño cual ser campeón del mundo yo
quería ser campeón del mundo hice todo
lo posible levantándome todos los días a
las 7 de la mañana y golpeándome con
todos los sparring por la tarde porque
tenía un sueño y llegó la oportunidad
italia 2003 en el adriático montesilvano
contra el campeón italiano campeonato
europeo quien lo ganara posiblemente
haría el mundial y peleé como nunca me
prepara preparé como jamás lo hice
la pelea de mi vida os digo una cosa yo
cuando subía por esas escalerillas
aunque llevaba a 69 peleas hechas yo no
sabía si era boxeador pero cuando baje
de esas escalerillas si sabía
y sabéis que el resultado me dieron
the door
perdí esa pelea
tres mil personas en el pabellón y
solamente 33 que puntuaban vieron otra
cosa
que si me enfadé pues claro que me
enfadé como no me voy a enfadar se gana
o se aprende y una
como que se ganó se aprende si se gana
se gana y si se pierde como te vayas a
esa esquina y te pongas a llorar te
paralice y te bloque es vas a estar
frustrado frustrado toda la vida sin
embargo te vas a la otra esquina llora
porque en esta vida hay que llorar
porque llorar no es de débiles este
vulnerables y vulnerables somos todos
lloras te limpias las lágrimas te
sientas
y reflexionar sobre dónde han estado los
errores ahí es cuando empiezas a
aprender de la derrota y yo reflexione
reflexione
pero reflexioné tanto que dude
y saber lo que ocurre que hay deportes
donde no se puede dudar motociclismo
automovilismo paracaidismo
y los deportes de contacto entre ellos
el boxeo no se puede dudar cuando se
duda paso atrás yo puse en una balanza
si seguía siendo peleador o seguía mi
carrera como entrenador que comenzaba en
esos momentos y en esa balanza en esa
duda estaba la decisión porque en esta
vida hay que tomar decisiones y yo la
tomé dejé mi sueño transforme mi sueño
deje mi deporte
porque yo para agradecer al boxeo todo
lo que ha hecho por mí debería de vivir
tres vidas es a mí ese deporte me dio
cinco superpoderes la constancia el
sacrificio la disciplina la motivación y
la pertenencia grupo y esos cinco
poderes yo los cogí con todas mis
fuerzas y conseguir controlar mis
emociones por fin yo encontré la paz
y entonces decidí no dar un paso atrás
decidí dar tres desde el centro del ring
y tres para ponerme en la esquina en la
esquina de mis peleadores porque todo el
mundo necesita una esquina todo el mundo
necesita una palmada en la espalda todo
el mundo necesita una voz valiente de
aliento todo el mundo
necesita que alguien le diga cuando no
puede más
un asalto más un asalto más
y cuando tú ya no puedes y no ves el
peligro que haya alguien que te cuide y
te proteja y sea capaz de tirar la
toalla entonces transforme mi sueño
decidí que ahora mi sueño era hacer
campeones del mundo y encamine mi
carrera como entrenador pronto vinieron
los premios campeones de españa
campeones de europa campeones del mundo
en el boxing full contact kick boxing
boxeo hasta monté mi propio gimnasio y
un día apareció
una niña en la puerta del gimnasio venía
acompañado de un amigo mío que iba a
preparar unas oposiciones y me dijo que
si la quería yo entré en albox o
femenino no esa época ni estaba ni se le
esperaba pero bueno estábamos empezando
pero venga que pase yo ya la conocía le
había visto pelear en full contac y la
niña tenía mimbres tenía fuerza
en la niña era un encanto siempre con
una sonrisa en la boca siempre simpática
agradable la verdad cada vez que entraba
al gimnasio lo alumbraba
y de la noche a la mañana
de la noche a la mañana esa niña ya no
miraba a los ojos esa niña
tenía ataques de ella esa niña empezó a
faltar empezó a engordar pero bueno
salió una pelea fuimos a hacerla
hicimos el ritual que tiene el mundo del
boxeo que es el pesaje el día anterior
se quitan las ropas ellos se quedan en
ropa interior sube el pesaje y veo algo
raro creo que se empieza a tapar
extraña qué es lo que pasa que familiar
y lo veo
y arañazos veo marcas veo moratones veo
golpes cuando baja le digo niña esto no
estoy del boxeo perdón hice fracturas de
nariz falta de pigmentación en los ojos
tus manos rotas sé perfectamente
las marcas que conlleva el boxeo ella se
bloquea se paraliza y sale corriendo
salgo corriendo detrás de ellas dos
semanas persiguiendo las no la encuentro
al final entras en la vorágine de la
vida
y se olvida al año y medio aparece en la
puerta del gimnasio con una niña en
brazos dice hero tengo que contarte algo
de hombre creo que sí me debes una
explicación
y me cuenta
el último año que está entrenando
conmigo
su pareja
estaba dando palizas
ya digo que sé que quiero hacer y me
dice que quiere entrenar cojo la niña y
le digo que pase
eso hace más de 15 años esa niña
ya no está el niño se llama miriam
gutiérrez es campeona de españa es
campeona de europa es campeona del mundo
profesional
no sólo eso ella es concejala de la
mujer de una de las poblaciones más
importantes de la comunidad de madrid
torrejón de ardoz ella ahora a través de
la política está intentando que no
ocurra lo mismo
definido por pedro simón uno de los
mejores periodistas de este país en la
portada de un periódico lo definió como
la historia más hermosa del deporte una
victoria labrada
en la peor de las derrotas
sabéis quién cayó derrotado ahí
me caí
no lo vi me caí
y tenía una opción levantarme para estar
de pie o para seguir peleando porque eso
no me podía volver a pasar ya no quería
ser campeón del mundo ya no querías
hacer yo campeones del mundo quería que
a ningún entrenador de este país le
pasara lo que me pasó a mí no ver las
violencias
delante de mi cara
así que empecé al día siguiente a
formarme en prevención de las violencias
al cabo de los años monté una fundación
con mi nombre que se dedica a la
prevención de las violencias
al cabo de los años de ir velando niños
que sufrían cualquier tipo de violencia
empecé a formar a la gente en prevención
de las violencias
voy por todo el mundo dando charlas de
prevención de las violencias
y siempre cuando dichas las de este tipo
la gente me dice
qué buen mensaje mandas y lo pienso
ojalá no fuera así
ojalá podría deciros que la vida
no va haber problemas en la vida no va a
haber problemas que todo va a ir bien
que no vais a tener que tomar decisiones
duras que os afecten a vosotros ya la
gente que tenéis alrededor
pero la legitimidad que me da que yo he
pasado por la vida y que la vida ha
pasado por mí
me dice que nuestra existencia son
golpes y decisiones y que las decisiones
más importantes que vamos a tomar en
nuestra vida son las que tomemos después
de los golpes
depende de cómo nos tomemos esas
decisiones y esos golpes obraremos en
consecuencia
permitirnos caer pero nunca nunca jamás
en la vida no intentéis
levantaron
si hay algo y no observable en esta vida
es que todo pasa
y todo se entrena y como dijo ese gran
filósofo de las 16 cuerdas llamado mike
tyson que todo el mundo tiene un plan
hasta que llega la primera
así que levantemos las manos pongámonos
en guardia
y preparémonos para esta vida
y ardua que es una pelea
que todavía le quedan muchos asaltos
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]